et nous retournerons chez nos amis
allemands tout au long de ce week-end
afin de mieux les comprendre
si tout va bien comme le souhaitent les
banquiers il n'y aura plus de billets de
banque dans 25 ans l'a mené le papier
monnaies seront remplacés par la carte
de crédit électronique ce sont les
conclusions de 650 banquiers
représentant 25 nations réunies à monte
carlo pour la troisième convention sur
les systèmes de paiement un reportage et
une enquête de michel chevalet sous la
carte il ay ay ay si si petit contact et
sous ses contacts il y a vous voyez un
petit micro processeurs avec ses
mémoires
et là on peut utiliser cette carte à mon
avis de trois façons avec sa mémoire
la première c'est d'utiliser cette
mémoire en quelque sorte comme un
chéquier électronique
il vous suffira d'introduire la carte
dans un lecteur approprié
chez les commerçants pour effectuer les
transactions et sur un écran vous verrez
s'afficher et bien en quelque sorte la
gestion de votre compte qui sera dans la
mémoire de la carte
la deuxième possibilité l'utilisation de
la mémoire de cette carte vous
appellerai le porte monnaie électronique
où on vous crédite rade une somme de 10
cents ou mille francs et vous pourrez
tout à votre guise utilisé soit pour les
places de cinéma soit encore regardez
bien dans les stations services
directement à la pompe à essence
enfin vous pourrez également par exemple
dans les cabines téléphoniques régler
directement vos communications sans
pièces de monnaie enfin la troisième
utilisation de ces cartes à mémoire
c'est peut-être la plus prometteuse et
c'est la première application grand
public
c'est en quelque sorte ici un bloc notes
or maintenant les porteurs de pacemakers
vous savez qu'ils sont plusieurs
milliers en france vont avoir une carte
et dans la mémoire de cette carte il y
aura les caractéristiques de leur
maladie les caractéristiques de
l'appareil
notez ici vous voyez dans cette carte
est dans presque tous les pays et en
quatre membres ont pour adresser le
diagnostic est notée de dans les
interventions pendant quatre ans